This last example actually gives us a clue as to how to find the horizontal
asymptote of a rational function. We started off with f of x equals 4 over x
minus 1 plus 1. And as x gets bigger, this fraction is going to get smaller and
smaller. Eventually we're going to end up with f of x equals 1 plus something
that's almost zero. This means, as we saw from the graph, that our horizontal
asymptote will be at y equals 1. So how can we reverse the process that we went
through of combining two fractions? In other words, if we started out with x
plus 3 over x minus 1, how can we get back to 1 plus 4 over X minus 1? Should
we divide the numerator by the denominator? Should we divide the denominator by
the numerator? Should we subtract the denominator from numerator? Or should we
subtract the numerator from the denominator?